we'll get five suggestions um we'll
divide you guys up in a segment someone
gets fair go then once we've got five
suggestions i'll do a freestyle rapper
if you are sat kind of it's just this
area what's your rapper
ah you're all laughing until i look at
you aren't you
so you so what what the [ __ ] is this
eastern european [ __ ] here
gambling ghibli yes okay like and what
did you what did you say
you said balkan i said you are you all
[ __ ] eastern european you are you
really are
wow okay gambling in the balkans what's
the main
what's the main type of gambling that
takes place in the balkans like which
donkey crossline first
only has two legs how it's even possible
two leg donkey
is that [ __ ] yeah illegal donkey
gambling in the balkans
[ __ ] bye everyone bye
there's literally no more terrifying
acts than that and that was the most
friendly balkan accent i've ever heard
like stop it man i kill you okay
seriously i'm not kidding
i have seen things
and done more okay
um okay so illegal gambling on donkeys
and the balkans
let's come to you guys here with your
rapper
it's a food and an animal they
immediately over there they were this
[ __ ] idiot
look if you're looking for someone to
enslave and take back that person there
come on do better than that
fine you guys don't get a suggestion
right
do you say california
let's focus what about california or
what's something in california you want
to focus on
it's expensive california's expensive
cool do you live there
[ __ ] move okay right
i lived in l.a for four years i was like
oh why am i really poor and then i moved
moved to colorado and i [ __ ] own
colorado now it's great
people people here what do you want to
rap about
what did you just say
because i heard the word beaver which is
an animal but then you added something
after which makes me think it's going to
be sexual
beaverton
beaver tail
this is
it's a dessert
[ __ ] you
don't move to wherever this person is
from
[ __ ] appalachia
somewhere
beavertail please explain to me what
beaver tail is
you said a donut
it's canadian okay a deep deep fried
canadian donut
okay
fried goodness in your lips did you say
i thought you would be the weirdest
people that i spoke to tonight
and you've been surpassed by everyone so
far expensive california donkey gambling
in the balkans
deep fried goodness in your lips yeah
thank you very much that is
no no this is what we're uh i i don't
know if this person even paid attention
no this is what we are rapping about
again i just take lots of topics because
i'm really good at this and it's really
boring if i just take one so front row
bachelor party hello what would you like
a rap about don't just pick the purse be
you know something make it special this
is your big night
why are you mocking the idea this is the
most important night of your life this
is
the last night you are a free man
look i'm married i've been married for
four years i i love being married i'm
very lucky but you know i'm
spectacularly talented at comedy so
i've [ __ ] found a keeper
you know i heard that you're a
journalist so the death of print media
what are you doing what do you want a
rapper
his money don't jiggle jiggle it folds
that's probably some tick-tock [ __ ]
in it that's what happens
when i don't know what it is and then
women go yeah
okay
that's what they've suggested for you
you're happy with that let's come over
here this this kind of enclave here oh
there's a lot of you okay let's take two
suggestions from here table of lads over
here
you've been spectacularly well behaved
and one of you has a luka modric top on
from which period in his career
i thought it was a spur shirt but then
you were all behaving so well i was like
these guys aren't british because
they will be so drunk by now um table of
not british labs what would you like a
rap about
oh there's one brit
we don't know each other it's a small
country but not
that small
all i know is that means there's one
person on your table with a foreskin
don't prove it british people love
proving it they whip out like that's
where i keep all my pound coins
so table of lads what do i wrap up
taxidermy cool yeah i like it guy over
there was [ __ ] astonished like whoa
no he didn't
no he did okay
um and then one final one from this area
sex in public cool great well
okay yeah what and what public
environment and don't don't say comedy
club
[Applause]
you had that prepared
an ice cream shop with someone who's
lactose intolerant okay sex in public in
an ice cream shop with someone who's
lactose intolerant taxidermy expensive
california beaver tails
gambling on donkeys in the balkans
and then his money don't jiggle jiggle
it folds
i love that you're just applauding an
act of memory that's all that was
right let's do this it's a freestyle do
me a favor drop that drop that beat it's
gonna be pretty bloody lovely this is a
new beat we'll see how it sounds i'm
excited um cool right we're gonna
[ __ ] let's start with this tick tock
[ __ ] because i don't even understand
that's fine
we'll do the donkeys later that's the
beast to go clip clock 15 seconds that's
the clip on the tick tock get a meme see
it on the screen his money don't jiggle
jiggle i'm not keen out resume that's
the coins in the pocket by your loins i
like to get the band no i might join my
british guy over there i was being funny
but he uses foreskin to contain that
money when you say it's folding no
mistake there you're holding the folding
money that'd be the paper i use a money
clip put it in my pocket it looks much
flyer than a hyper thin wallet this is
what they selected for you bachelor you
were raising your eyebrow really kind of
sure i can stop that
[Music]
you need to use the corn flour
internally and maybe get some little
kind of hydrochlorofilm put the little
four mile to hide you know the beast you
killed put it in a glass case right
first looking like an artist like maybe
damien hurst and if i did some taxidermy
that failed
i'm hungry yes i provide some tasty
goodness for your lips and you know that
it's fried no it's no butts i eat the
doughnuts north of the border i feel in
luck i assume the calorie count is all
so painful you'll have to
[Music]
sit there
i'm shaking all the coins looking kind
of pensive you've got less money than
the place expensive the californians
that's the a true son they try to recall
gavin newsom we need to get more money
in the budget but back to the balkans i
can't budget out of my mind i love the
baltic port and that's technically my
polling this out of all the action focus
on belarus and
europeans yes i adore you don't blush if
you're from rush ah it doesn't matter
lips but you're hush uh the donkey there
crossing the finish line but no jesus on
the back this time and i find an urge to
go and have some sense i look around
local neighborhoods are crying and
spitting i see a sexy lady behind the
counter it's 12 in the afternoon i still
mount up i bring her over here remove
her clothes i'm like oh yes are you
lactose she starts sneezing bleeding
from her nose and her mouth it doesn't
matter cause i'm getting cheeky down
south you can call me mr whippy when i
slap it when i'm in the ice cream store
from the back make no mistake i give the
girl a flake that's the type of
chocolate thing in the top that we take
she's like oh having sex in public oh so
many look at us while we [ __ ] there with
the better cherries i get a giving me
head that's the head bob in so many
flavors you can call me baskin robbins
[Applause]